-Do you ever see a photo
in the news
and think the headline
should be different?
I'll show you. We'll take care
of that right now.
It's time for
"News & Improved."
Here we go.
-♪ News and improved ♪
-The headline could be better.
-Sure.
-Let me give you an example.
This first photo here.
The original headline was...
That headline can
definitely be improved.
Because if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could have been...
-Aww.
[ Applause ]
-Up next, this headline says...
Headline could have been...
It's like, "Oh. Sorry!
I didn't see anything."
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I'm gonna go see 'Avatar.'"
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
"No specials because
everything here is a special?"
[ Laughs hysterically ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
-Oh. Wow.
[ Applause ]
-Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
The next headline was...
Headline could have been...
"Oh! Curry, over here!
Steph, Steph! Right here, man!"
[ Applause ]
And, finally,
this headline was...
Headline could have been...